- The project that the New York Times
was given a Pulitzer for this year,
of recasting the history
of the United States
in terms of slavery as
the primary narrative,
the 1619 Project,
seems to me just to be
fundamentally historically wrong.
It's a distortion.
This isn't to say that
slavery didn't matter,
it just doesn't mean it's not important.
It's just that if you
were to try to explain
the significance of the United States
to a visiting Martian,
you wouldn't start with slavery
because that wasn't really an especially
unique feature of the United States.
There was slavery and it
lasted much longer in Brazil.
There was slavery and it was far harsher
in the Caribbean colonies
of Britain and other European states.
So what's the defining characteristic?
What's the thing that makes
the United States distinctive?
It's not slavery.
(dramatic music)
- This is the Rubin Report,
and according to Big Tech, I'm Dave Rubin.
I remind everybody to subscribe
to our YouTube channel
and click that notification
bell for notifications.
That's what the bell's there for.
And joining me today is a historian
and Senior Fellow at
the Hoover Institution
at Stanford University.
Niall Ferguson, welcome
back to the Rubin report.
- It's great to be back virtually, Dave.
I'd prefer to be back really, but hey.
It's the plague year.
- It is the plague year!
You know, last time you were on the show,
you flew in, you bolted from the airport,
we talked as fast as we could
for about an hour and a half,
and then you bolted and left again.
So this must be very calming for you,
to be able to be at home
and relax and at a computer.
'Cause you're a busy guy.
- It is very calming.
I had not spent three months
in one location for 20 years.
And I think I had fallen
victim to hyper mobility
and hyper globalization where,
if I wasn't on a long-haul
flight at least once a week,
I felt there was something
wrong with my life.
And having that all stop,
has been a real blessing.
Not everybody gets to work from home,
I'm one of the lucky ones who can.
And, this is also meant
more time with my family.
So I think we all may have been suffering
from some kind of collective FOMO,
as we flew from conference
to conference manically.
And COVID-19 stopped the world and said,
you can all get off now.
And for some people, it's been difficult.
For me, it's been literally coming home,
but also metaphorically,
because I'm back to the kind of life I had
when I was a young academic,
teaching at Oxford, with little kids,
and that was my life.
I read books, I wrote books,
and I read stories at night.
And I'm back to that, and it's great.
- Well as most of my audience knows,
your wife is the magical, amazing,
I'll let you add a
couple other adjectives,
Ayaan Hirsi Ali.
And you guys do have a toddler now.
So, look at you, enjoying home life.
You're supposed to be a stodgy academic,
and you're enjoying home life.
- Well we have two sons, actually.
I'll add the adjectives, shall I, Dave?
Brave, beautiful and brilliant.
Those are the three things
that describe my wife,
and she's also a wonderful mother.
And our two sons,
one of whom is eight and the other is two,
are a constant source of joy to us.
And I'm just seeing much more of them,
which is fascinating.
I thought homeschooling was an oxymoron,
and it turns out actually
to work quite well,
at least with some kids.
Thomas, who's eight, has been,
he's really been, in
some ways, more engaged,
because he's had greater
freedom to explore.
And I've been fascinated to watch him
become a little autodidact,
and delve deeply into STEM subjects.
So yeah, there is all
sorts of wonderful things
that have come out of
2020, which is paradoxical,
because it's been a horrible
year for so many people.
- Whoa, STEM subjects?
I thought STEM subjects were all racist
and patriarchal and part
of the oppressive machinery
that is the West or something like that.
You're teaching STEM
subjects to an 8-year-old?
- Well he's teaching them to himself.
Remember, although I'm
from a science background,
my mother is a physicist
and so is my sister,
I'm the black sheep of the family
who wandered off into
the dangerous terrain
of the humanities and social sciences,
but Thomas is a young
man with a clear vision.
I think he's identified that humanities
and the social sciences are
no longer the places to be,
and he's been studying microbiology
with considerable zeal,
entirely at his own initiative.
Thomas also had the
best insights about 2020
that I've yet heard from anybody.
He said, "Dad, there are
two pandemics this year."
I said, "Really, what's the other one?"
"Well there's obviously COVID-19
but there's another pandemic
which is more contagious.
And it's called woked-19.
And you can catch Woked-19
from the internet,
so it's more dangerous than COVID-19."
I think there's wisdom
among the 8-year-olds, Dave.
They give me hope.
- You know, most people make up
what their 8-year-olds are saying,
but I actually believe that
you and Ayaan's offspring said that.
You know a lot of the Twitter warriors,
they sit there pretending, yeah.
- It's really one of his many insights
into this strange time.
I do think his generation
is going to surprise people,
if he and his friends
are anything to go by.
There's a kind of healthy skepticism,
a sort of South Park
quality to this generation.
They are very different in their outlook,
as far as a I can see, from
a admittedly small sample,
from the Generation Z 20-somethings,
who are currently in
various stages of anxiety
and wokeness.
So I have a suggestion,
which I'm sure is impossible to do more
than just speculate about,
'cause we can't poll 8-year-olds.
But I think Generation T,
the kids who came of age
during the Trump presidency,
are gonna have very different outlooks.
Partly because I think
they've been slightly
forcefed woke ideas at school,
and they do react like Cartman and Kyle
and the kids from South Park.
Which I find quite encouraging.
Because at eight, I was a kind
of instinctive conservative.
I think most 8-year-olds are.
You're kind of against change,
even when your parents
change the wallpaper
in the living room.
You're kind of against it.
And I noticed certain
familiar symptoms in Thomas.
I hope it doesn't all go away
when he becomes a teenager.
That would be awful.
- Well, he's gonna have
to go through a phase,
I hate to tell you.
That's how it works.
- Well not necessarily,
because in Britain,
we have boarding schools,
and you just send away your children
the minute they become teenagers.
And then they hate
teachers instead of you.
It works remarkably well.
- That's actually pretty clever.
All right, so we're gonna do something
a little bit different
than I would normally do
if I was to have you on.
I wanna use the time with you,
to sort of celebrate America,
and celebrate freedom.
This is gonna be our July 4th special.
We're taping it a little
bit before July 4th.
But because you have an
interesting immigration story,
your wife has an interesting
immigration story,
you are a historian,
and a proud American,
I thought you were the right
guy to talk to about this.
But before we fully get into that,
am I correct, you've written 14 books?
Is that right?
- I think it might be 15, actually.
- Is it 15 now?
- Yeah, I think so, yeah.
- That's a lot of books.
I don't even have a question to ask.
I just wanted to say it,
'cause it's an awful lot of books.
And as a guy that just wrote one,
I just feel like you
deserve some credit on that.
- Well the only consolation is,
I think each one is easier
than the one before.
So the first one is the hard one.
You know, it's not like it's an art.
Writing books is more
like building cabinets.
It's a sort of craft.
And once you've done it once,
the second one is distinctly easier.
That's the good news.
There are people more prolific than I am.
And indeed, one of my heroes,
the Scottish novelist, John Buchan,
regarded it as a kind of wasted year
if he hadn't written a book.
Whereas I think my batting average
is a book every two
and a half years or so.
I'm not exceptionally prolific.
But I did used to look around
at certain universities where I've worked
and marveled at how few books
some of my colleagues were able to write.
I don't know what they were
doing the rest of the time.
I live to write,
and reading and writing are the two things
that I do with the greatest facility.
The thinking in the middle
is the difficult bit.
You do the reading and then
the hard bit is the thinking.
Once you've figured it out,
the writing is a relatively
straightforward part of the job.
- All right, so between
the personal story,
the writing,
and a little bit of the thinking,
let's talk about freedom.
So first, I just thought,
telling a bit about your own
personal immigration story
would be kind of interesting.
You wrote a blog about it a while back,
and I think that might be a nice way
to set this whole conversation up.
- Well I've been working
in the United States
since around 2002.
I was transatlantic for a while,
going back and forward very regularly.
And it took a while
before I realized that,
when I was landing at Boston Logan,
that felt more like coming home,
than landing at Heathrow.
It was kind of a gradual process.
I decided to come to the United States
partly out of a sense
that action was here.
In my field, I was writing
a lot of financial history,
I'd written the history
of the Rothschilds.
The English, by and large,
like their historians
to do kings and queens,
prime ministers, not bankers.
New York kinda got what I was
doing more than London did.
And I was kinda toying with the idea
of a move to New York
University, when 9/11 happened.
Now the Scots have a propensity
to march towards the sound of gunfire,
and I was so pissed at the terrorists
for attacking New York,
and so determined that they shouldn't,
in any way, derail my plan,
that, in fact. almost immediately
after the 9/11 attacks, I said to NYU,
"Look, I'm open to an offer
if you're interested."
And they more or less faxed
one back the next day.
So I resigned from Oxford
and moved to NYU shortly after 9/11
and spent two happy years in New York.
Everybody should live in New York
for at least a couple of years.
And then moved to Harvard.
So that was sort of the
beginning of an American journey
that was intellectually captivating.
We went, as you'll recall, very quickly
from the terrorists
attacks to the Iraq war
and debates about American empire,
which dominated the
administration of George W. Bush.
Now I'd just written a book
about the British empire,
so it was natural to start thinking about
those contemporary American issues.
But as I said in that
time, I was transatlantic,
I was very much the British
historian in the United States,
sort of a stock figure.
It was only gradually
that I began to realize
that my future was in the United States,
and that if I was going to
live here and work here,
and not be a transatlantic
bird of passage,
than I should really go from
being a Green Card holder,
to becoming a citizen.
And I did that almost
exactly two years ago.
I just wanna stress,
I'm a legal immigrant.
So I jumped through the various hoops
you need to jump through,
held a bunch of visas.
And then I became a citizen.
And it seems to many of
my European contemporaries
like a crazy thing to do.
What, becoming an American,
under the Trump presidency?
Are you crazy?
In this time of disruption?
And my response was, well yeah.
Part of the reason for doing that
is the recognition that
you're not signing up
for a particular president,
you're signing up for the Constitution,
you're signing up for the
ideals of the founders.
And as I've said often to Ayaan,
I think we immigrants have a better
appreciation of American freedoms
of the first principles of the republic.
Better than native born Americans
'cause we've seen some
of the alternatives.
Now for Ayaan, the alternatives
were a great deal worse.
If you were a girl growing up in Somalia,
there aren't really too
many freedoms whatsoever.
I grew up in Scotland, I grew
up in the United Kingdom,
and in many ways, you
could say the United States
is a sort of outgrowth
of the British empire.
So there's a less obvious contrast.
But there still is a contrast.
And I've been aware of it
ever since I was a kid.
- Can you talk about that contrast?
I'm interested in that,
just either from a Scottish
or a British perspective,
to then come to America and see freedom,
or live freedom in a new way.
Like, what types of things,
at a granular level, did you feel?
Did you feel freer as a historian,
to talk about certain things?
Or was it just more
about the American ethos,
or what was it?
- Those are great questions, Dave.
First, there's a little bit of
romance to the United States
that you mustn't lose sight of.
If you're growing up in Glasgow,
where it rains all the time,
the romance of the Western,
the romance of American music,
the romance of American literature,
these are powerful attractive forces.
And so in the (audio distortion)
Glasgow in the 1970s,
you've got to picture
a spotty teenage Niall
reading Jack Kerouac,
watching Clint Eastwood,
and listening to a lot of American music.
I became a Jazz enthusiast as a teenager.
You can see my double bass
in the background there.
And that's American music, par excellence.
So I think there's a
romance piece to this,
that one shouldn't underestimate.
But there's an intellectual piece too.
I was steeped in the values
of the Scottish Enlightenment as a boy,
the ideals of Adam Smith,
the very individualistic
culture of 18th century
Glasgow and Edinburgh.
But those values had really declined
in their significance in Scotland.
Socialism had caught fire in Scotland
in the early 20th century,
I had a great uncle who was a communist,
many other people around us
were die-hard labor supporters.
And those Enlightened ideals
of individual responsibility,
of the free market,
they had already faded,
to the point that the Scots
hated Margaret Thatcher
for espousing those principles.
Now what's attractive
to an immigrant like me
about the United States is that,
in some places, not
everywhere, but in some places,
you can still find those
Enlightenment values.
And they're being lived,
they're practiced.
That's a very attractive feature.
I think it's also true that
when a Scotsman comes to England,
he's constantly conscious
of his being Scottish.
The English are obsessed with class,
the way Americans are obsessed with race.
Everything is about class in England.
And the question is always, well,
which school did you go to, really?
And can you just do something
about that funny accent of yours?
So I never really felt
wholly at home in England,
though I lived for many years
there in Oxford and Cambridge.
And felt much more at home
as soon as I arrived in the United States.
The English believe in
effortless superiority.
They think you should just
sort of be born superior.
Americans believe in work,
and they don't begrudge success.
And so if you were a kind of ambitious,
hardworking Scotsman,
this is a more natural
habitat for you than England.
So, for all those reasons,
it didn't take long to feel
at home in the United States,
perhaps more at home than
I'd ever felt in England.
There's quite a lot of Scottish,
in the kind of the
foundations of this country.
And when Alexander Hamilton
suddenly became a household name
thanks to Lin-Manuel Miranda's musical,
that was nice because
he'd been a kind of hero,
long before he became
famous again, in our family.
My mother's name is Hamilton.
The Scots love to say they
invented the modern world,
and so naturally, that includes
inventing the United States,
or at least its fiscal systems.
So for a whole bunch of reasons,
this country was always
powerfully attractive to me.
I hitchhiked across America
before I went off to university,
at the age of 17.
I actually reenacted Jack
Kerouac's "On the Road"
with considerable
fidelity to the original.
So yeah, the American dreamers
come in many forms for me.
And that's, I think, ultimately why
becoming a citizen was exciting.
The whole process was exciting.
Even although it had
its surreal side to it.
- Did you notice the
difference on the academic side
when you were with intellectuals,
the way European intellectuals
would perhaps talk about something,
versus the way Americans did?
Maybe a different focus
or anything like that?
- Well you know, I think
there's a disappointment,
which I need to admit to.
I came to the United States
believing that American universities
were the places where
the biggest intellects
had the biggest arguments.
And that was part of
the appeal of Harvard.
I admit there was this sense
that Oxford and Cambridge
had been the great universities
of the 19th and 20th century
but now in the 21st century,
you really wanted to be at Harvard.
And I think over time,
it was a slow process.
I became disillusioned
with the American academy.
And I found that it was becoming
less and less hospitable to the kind of
rambunctious free inquiry
that motivates me.
And now I've reached the point
where I look back nostalgically
on the Oxford of the 1980s,
where there was simply no question
of your free speech being circumscribed.
On the contrary in the 1980s,
we kind of found ourselves constantly
pushing the boundaries
of what could be said.
As undergraduates, we found our professors
were intellectually an
extraordinarily diverse bunch.
There were the die-hard Marxists,
the kind of Eric Hobsbawm types.
And then there were the High
Tories, the Jeremy Cattos.
And it was a tremendously
enriching experience.
Academic life in the United States,
especially in the last,
I'll say, five years,
as Jonathan Haidt and others have noted,
has really really been
damaged by a culture
of what used to be called
political correctness
but I don't think that quite captures it.
A fundamental intolerance
of a deep illiberalism,
a deep hostility to free
debate and free inquiry,
that is killing the great
institutions of American academia.
So yeah, I mean, I'm as proud as could be,
of being an American,
but I'm at the same time,
depressed by some of the trends
that I see in the country today,
because they seem so at odds
with the first principles
of American life.
- Is it weird for you to see this spread
across the world at the same time?
Because last year when I was at Oxford,
and I got to speak at Oxford Union,
which I still, it sort
of feels like a dream
that I even got to speak there,
but just being there and being around
the hundreds of years of history,
and walking around,
and you feel this thing that you guys have
that we have much less of, obviously,
because of the breadth of history,
you feel this generation after generation
of caring about knowledge and
history and all these things.
And even just in the last couple of days,
I've seen these articles that Oxford,
their professors are pushing
to have more lenient grades
for students of color,
and just the rest of the sort of,
what I would call, intellectual rot,
that we've seen across these schools.
It must be particularly painful for you
to see it happen at a place like Oxford.
- I think so, although I
sometimes get the sense
that it's not that
deep, the rot in Oxford.
For example, I was very pleased
that the Vice Chancellor,
Louise Richardson, and other
leaders of the university,
dismissed again the calls to tear down
a statue of Cecil Rhodes
that stands in Oriel College.
Cambridge, I think, has
been rather more inclined
to appease these forces of iconoclasm.
It is iconoclasm, the
tearing down of statues.
And I know that I'm a conservative,
when I see statues being torn down,
and a little part of me winces,
it doesn't really much
matter who the statue is.
I prefer statues to be built.
And I think Oxford has held
the line there, thus far.
But as is always the case,
there are elements within
any academic society that,
let's see the opportunities
in the ideologies of wokeness.
See ways in which they can
advance their own careers
by championing these
outlandish and illiberal ideas.
The great danger is
that it becomes a norm,
that a university should be
intellectually homogenous.
That we should pursue
every kind of diversity,
except intellectual and
ideological diversity.
And I worry that eventually,
what has been happening
in American universities,
will overcome the healthier
forces at Oxford and Cambridge.
That's not to say that we couldn't
do more at these universities,
to make them attractive
to, and appealing to,
people from minority communities,
and from the white working class,
which is notably
underrepresented at these places.
But the mistake that's
always made in these debates
is to think that the problem
lies with the universities,
rather than with the systems of education
that simply discourage students,
or make them unable to
apply to elite institutions.
I've always said I believe passionately
in educational opportunity,
and the social mobility that it creates.
My parents were the
first in their families
to go to university.
And what I see in the
United States and in the UK,
are failing schools that don't
allow talented young people,
whether they're from minority communities
or from the working class,
to get anywhere close to
applying to elite universities.
That's what we need to fix.
And there are lots of ways of doing it,
but one doesn't hear those discussed.
- So I know we could spend eight hours
dissecting wokeness and the rest of it.
But I wanna shift from it a little bit,
but I just have one other
question on the woke thing,
since we've treaded into those waters.
As a conservative academic,
you were obviously,
and we talked a little
bit about this last time,
on the outside of what
most academic circles
think is acceptable, even
in history department.
Do you think that conservatives
have a better defense
against wokeness than liberals?
So for example, Jon Haidt,
who I've had on the show,
and many of the other academics
that you know that I've talked to,
that come from the more Liberal side,
I sense that although they're
making good arguments,
I don't think they have
good defenses against this,
because of the sort of
openness of liberalism,
that it's being used against itself.
And I do sense that conservatism,
as a world view, or as
a philosophical lens,
does have some protections
that liberalism doesn't.
Do you agree with that?
- Well it's true that we wouldn't
be in quite this situation
if it hadn't been for liberal professors,
giving jobs to progressive professors,
who then gave jobs to Marxists
and cultural Marxists.
I mean, conservative academic,
conservative professors,
these are becoming oxymorons,
because there are so
few conservatives left
in the American academy.
I mean the figures are clear,
it's not like this is an old
problem that we've always had.
Over time, the ratio of registered
Democrats to Republicans,
has risen steadily to the point that
you can't calculate it in some departments
'cause there are zero Republicans.
And I think that trend
broadly is explicable
because liberals felt
that they should hire
people to the left of them,
underestimating the extent
to which those people
would fundamentally differ
on the principles of,
say, the project of
historical scholarship.
It is not the goal of a history department
to impose on the past,
the ideals of the progressives of 2020,
that's the ultimate
condescension to the past.
Conservatives have understood
better, I think, the dangers.
And the tragedy has
been that conservatives
have been poorly organized.
I mean the extinction of conservatives in,
say, history departments,
isn't just the fault of
liberals hiring progressives.
It's also that the
conservatives did poorly
when it came to the
most basic organization
that has to happen in academia.
The patronage networks,
getting your students into good positions.
I don't think conservatives
were very good at that.
My conservative mentors were
wonderful intellectuals.
People like Norman Stone.
But Norman would not
be remembered, I think,
for his organizational skills.
For his writing, certainly.
But definitely not for his
deftness at academic politics.
So it's partly I think
because conservatives
were rather too busy writing books
and perhaps occasionally
drinking bottles of wine,
and not working hard enough
at the committee stages
to make sure that the
right candidates got hired.
- It's interesting and I think,
that right there almost
explains everything
happening in the world right now.
That we let all these
kids out after watching
academia sort of crumble, and here we are.
But shifting from that,
from a historian's perspective,
what do you think that the
average American should know
about the history of America,
that we don't know, or
that we under-appreciate?
Because you know, we
seem to live in a time
where we're erasing our own history,
and we're taking down monuments
and we're destroying the names
of people that were flawed
but that were just people of their time?
- Well I think the challenge here
is that history is not monochrome.
The history of any great society or state
can't be told as a eulogy,
nor as a kind of criminal indictment.
And the good historian
of the United States,
or for that matter, of the United Kingdom,
acknowledges that there are
debits as well as credits,
that there's shadows, there's
dark sides to the story,
as well as bright sides.
And this is a challenge that
I didn't think was difficult
when I was writing earlier in my career.
I wrote a history of the British empire,
which included a chapter
on the American Revolution.
And the book sets out very plainly,
that there are many stains on the history
of the British empire,
including, of course,
the central role of slavery
in the southern colonies
that became the southern
states of the United States.
But the point of that book,
and I make the same argument about
the history of the United States,
is that the benefits outweigh the costs.
That the successes were
more important, ultimately,
than the failures.
The project that the New York Times
was given a Pulitzer for this year,
of recasting the history
of the United States,
in terms of slavery as
the primary narrative,
the 1619 Project,
seems to me just to be
fundamentally historically wrong.
It's a distortion.
This isn't to say that
slavery didn't matter,
it just doesn't mean it's not important.
It's just that if you
were to try to explain
the significance of the United
States to a visiting Martian,
you wouldn't start with slavery,
because that wasn't really
an especially unique feature
of the United States.
There was slavery and it
lasted much longer in Brazil,
there was slavery and it was far harsher
in the Caribbean colonies
of Britain and other European states.
So what's the defining characteristic,
what's the thing that makes
the United States distinctive?
It's not slavery,
anymore than if you looked at
Western civilization broadly.
It would be true to say that imperialism
is the defining characteristic.
Everybody did empire,
just as slavery goes way back before 1619,
all the way to ancient times.
And by the way, still exists.
There is still slavery.
There are slave markets
where people are sold.
There are slave economies,
which rely on slave labor today.
So it can't really be true to say
that the interesting thing,
the thing you really need to know
about the United States is slavery.
But the interesting thing
about the United States
is that it represented an
experiment in governance,
a radical experiment based on
ideas from the Enlightenment,
and earlier ideas from the
Protestant Reformation,
it's fair to say.
And this produced an
extraordinary Constitution,
which has stood up to all
the stresses and the strains
of history since the late 18th century.
And understanding that
peculiar Constitution,
that very distinctive document,
with its separation of powers,
and its careful preservations
of individual (audio distortion),
that should be your top priority
if you're studying American history.
Not to the exclusion of the bad stuff.
There's plenty of bad stuff
that we need to study.
But I don't think we should
be teaching young Americans,
from how it Howard Zinn's
"A People's History of the United States,"
in which the negatives are constantly
emphasized over the positives.
That just seems to me to miss the point
of the American story completely.
- Are you worried that the
extraordinary pressures
that we're facing right now,
between the pandemic,
between riots and protests,
between polarization that
really is off the charts,
and then throw in social media,
which is just gas on the flame,
are you worried that those pressures
could snap that project in a way
that it hasn't been snapped before?
Or certainly in the last
hundred years, let's say?
- Dave, let me give you a somewhat
surprising answer to that question.
I'd be worried if we weren't worried.
One of the things about this country
that's very distinctive is that
we're always worried that
the Republic's gonna end.
We're always kinda fretting
about the coming tyranny,
the impending civil war.
And thus far, there
has been one civil war,
and no dictatorships.
And that's kind of encouraging.
I think that's partly
because we worry about it.
And I think it's a healthy
feature of American life also,
to expect decline.
People have been predicting the
decline of the United States
throughout my life.
It was a preoccupation of Henry Kissinger,
whose biography, I'm in
the midst of writing.
In the 1970s, it seems
as if the United States
was being torn apart by Vietnam,
torn apart by its racial divisions,
torn apart by a president
who had violated his oath office,
all of that we've seen before.
And I think it's part of the
way the United States works,
that we're always expecting
the disintegration of the Republic
and the descend into civil war.
And I think we'll have
to start being nervous
if we stop worrying about that stuff.
But as long as we have-
My old friend, Andrew Sullivan,
so fretful about the coming Trump tyranny,
that he doesn't quite spot
the tyranny of the left,
until it's right up behind him.
I mean that's kind of the
predicament that I think
a lot of liberals and
conservatives find themselves in.
That they were so indignant and dismayed
by Trump back in 2016,
that they slightly underestimated
the rather more operationally worrying
tyrannical tendencies of the radical left.
So yeah, I think we should
keep worrying about this stuff.
And as long as we're worrying about it,
we'll probably be okay.
- Yeah, does it also strike you as odd,
or maybe obvious,
relative to social media,
that when something happens here,
that it suddenly happens everywhere?
I mean, we've all seen the videos now
of literally police officers in London,
being hunted down by mobs.
That has nothing to do,
in any concrete sense,
with what happened to George Floyd,
and yet, it seems like if
there's an incident here,
it's now exported everywhere.
- I think future historians
will wonder why it was,
that in the midst of a pandemic,
which is far from over,
Americans decided to have a
debate about police violence
towards African Americans.
Not to say that that's not
an important issue to think about,
but it seems an odd time
to have that debate,
and to start debates about
defunding the police,
when we should really be wondering
what went wrong with
the Department of Health
and Human Services and CDC
when they ought to have taken far better
and earlier action to
contain the contagion.
There's something strange,
it's a non sequitur,
that in the midst of this
massive public health crisis,
which has killed nearly 120,000 Americans
and will probably kill another 120,000
before the end of the year,
we're having this debate.
But the second part I'd make is that,
the internet has created
a new kind of contagion.
As I said earlier, quoting my son,
there are two pandemics.
And the second pandemic, in fact,
predates the murder of George Floyd,
because it's a pandemic of protests,
that you could actually see in Hong Kong,
in San Diego, in Barcelona, in
cities like Beirut last year.
And what is interesting to me is that
the mode of protest is
consistently the same.
The content varies from place to place,
but this quality of protest to go viral,
styles of protests to be copied,
from Hong Kong to Minneapolis,
is really interesting.
I mean, historically, the police
had better communications
than demonstrators,
for most of the second
half of the 20th century.
That the police had walkie talkies,
and the demonstrators were
lucky if they had megaphones.
But the smartphone has changed that.
And it's allowed protestors
to really organize
these acephalous networks,
where there is no obvious leader.
And actually have superior
comms to the police.
So I think what's interesting about
the great eruption of
protests that we've seen
in the last month in the United States,
it is that, actually,
it's, in terms of its form,
quite a close copy of the Hong
Kong protests of last year.
It's just that the content's different.
And I think you can keep these
sorts of protest waves going
as long as people have viral video,
as well as sort of tips
on organizing a protest
that they can simply download
and apply it to their context.
That I think is the really
interesting feature.
It's not the content of the
protests that's the same,
as in previous waves of revolution.
Here, it's just the form
of protest that's the same.
The content varies from place to place.
- Yeah, it's interesting.
So you're saying you're not
worried because we worry.
And then on the other hand,
there is this other pathogen or virus,
or whatever you wanna call it,
that really does make this something
that we've just never dealt with before.
- I think we've dealt with the
revolutionary crowd before.
It's just the revolutionary crowd
didn't have smartphones before.
I was fascinated by the way
in which the Hong Kong protestors
outsmarted the police there, last year.
Partly by constantly changing
the form of the protest,
partly by not having leaders
that you could just round up,
partly by shifting away from violence,
when violence was alienating local people.
And I think we saw
something of that happen.
Because in June, there
was a period earlier on
when the protests were quite
violent, and there was looting,
and that actually was quite
unhelpful to the protestors' cause.
And then you saw a shift
in the style of protests in many places.
So this shape-shifting quality
of the crowd with smartphones,
is an interesting thing to observe.
I don't think it's necessarily
a disastrous phenomenon.
Because in some context,
these protests achieve
successful outcomes.
You know, crowds aren't always bad.
There are even occasions
when you can justify
pulling down a statue,
think New York, 1776.
But my sense is that on the specific issue
that is being addressed in
the United States today,
which has to do with changing
the way the police operate,
there is a big disconnect between
what is said by protestors,
and indeed by Black Lives Matter,
and what we know from good social science,
the real problem is.
And I do think it's difficult for a crowd
to read social science
and arrive at actionable
policy recommendations.
That tends not to happen.
- Is that the biggest danger
that we have going right now?
That there's a certain set of people
that it doesn't matter what
the social science says,
it doesn't matter what the facts say.
That their ideology overrides all of that.
So this sort of goes
back to what I was saying
about our liberal academics friends.
It's like, you guys can make
sound arguments all day long,
that's great, I love it,
I'll do it all day with you.
But that doesn't actually
address the problem
because there's something
else going on here,
that can't be rationalized out of.
- Right, and I think
the case of Roland Fryer
illustrates many of the predicaments
that we find ourselves in today.
Roland, who wrote some pioneering papers
as a Harvard economist, in 2016,
published an extraordinarily
important study showing that,
while the police did disproportionately
shove, push, and otherwise
manhandle African Americans,
compared with white suspects,
they did not disproportionately
shoot African Americans.
And that finding was an
extremely important one,
since at the core of Black Lives Matter,
was a claim that the police
disproportionately use
lethal violence against black people.
And it turns out not to be true.
But what became of Roland
after that publication?
He knew there would be
blowback, and there was.
But what actually happened was not at all
what he or I or his friends had expected.
What happened was that he was
accused of sexual harassments
by a former employee,
white, incidentally,
and then found himself sucked into
a Title IX investigation at Harvard,
which I think was actually a
grave miscarriage of justice.
And it's hard to avoid the suspicion
that if Roland's research had arrived
at a more politically correct conclusions,
that were more compatible
with progressive narratives,
perhaps that might not have happened.
I certainly think that there
is something to be asked,
some hard questions to be asked,
about why an African American professor,
who started life in the wrong
side of the tracks in Texas,
has had first hand experiences
of police brutality,
why he should have ended up
being treated in this way
by mostly white progressive administrators
at the country's most well-known
and eminent university.
It's something that's been
on my mind for some time now
since the case against him was brought.
And I sense that ultimately,
we won't really be able to arrive
at a serious discussion of these issues,
data-based, and also based
on personal experience,
as long as Roland's being
canceled in the name of Me Too.
- So in a weird way, do
you need the institutions
to crumble so that
something better can happen?
Like it seems like we're sort of just
in a slow crumble phase right now.
There doesn't seem to be
any great institution,
whether it's Harvard
or the New York Times,
or a series of other things,
that we sort of all look to
as the guardians of the Republic.
They're all sort of crumbling.
Do you think they have
to crumble, to re-set?
Or do you think they can actually
just re-put together?
Just put together the pieces again?
- Well I think one of the lessons
of American history is that, at its best,
the United States
creates new institutions,
rather than just gives
the old ones makeovers.
I think one of the sad
features of our time
is that the great Plutocrats
of our gilded age,
have not created new universities,
as their predecessors did
in the late 19th century.
But have simply given money
to the existing institutions,
and in particular to institutions that
already had tons of money.
And my recommendation to
today's robber barons,
or if you wanna put it politely,
titans of Silicon Valley
and Wall Street is,
just remember the
examples of the Carnegies,
and do some innovation here,
build some new institutions.
You don't like what's happening
at Harvard or Yale or Stanford,
well, there's nothing to stop you
creating a new institution.
Because that's the American way.
What Tocqueville noticed,
the great French political theorist,
Alexis de Tocqueville,
when he came to the United States
before writing his great
book, "Democracy in America,"
was that Americans then,
did not expect the government
to solve their problems.
They did it through associational life.
And for me, the most striking
feature of this American story
is this readiness for
people at the local level
to deal with problems locally,
to build civic institutions locally,
and not to expect the federal government
or for that matter, Harvard
or the New York Times,
to come up with solutions.
So I desperately feel a
need for new institutions.
And not only at the level of colleges.
I think we need new schools.
There's been some innovation
in that direction,
in the Charter-School Movement,
but it's still really a drop in the bucket
of what needs to happen to improve
American secondary education,
which is the real weakness
that this country is burdened with.
So I think we just need
to remind ourselves that,
in its original design,
the United States was supposed to be,
a, decentralized,
with b, small government,
c, a vibrant associational
life and religious life,
and crucially, a sort
of constant formation
of new institutions.
That that was what you did,
if you'd been successful,
if you'd had the American
capitalist dream.
Giving back involve more than just
a new building at Harvard
with your name on it.
Giving back meant a new university,
something that hadn't existed before.
That's what we seemed to have lost.
And I'm really struck by
that lack of new institutions
as one of the pathologies,
one of the signs,
of our recent degeneration.
- So you don't think that
the Harvard endowment,
which is worth what, $40 billion,
you don't think they
need a couple more bucks?
- Well, far be it for me to
advise America's philanthropists
where they should put their money.
But if they applied the kind
of due diligence standards
that they apply when they're making
investments to their philanthropy,
then I think they might
at least think twice.
'Cause the return on
investment that you get
from donating to an already
established institution,
just can't be that high.
I mean, what real marginal impact
does a million dollars make to Harvard?
Whereas if you were to use the money
to create something new,
the return on investment would
potentially be far higher.
So I think there's a need
for new institutions.
I think it would help revitalize.
Just as we should have new statues.
If you don't like the old ones,
why not build some new statues
rather than wasting your
energies on vandalism?
One of my favorite
sculptors, Sandy Stoddart,
who's a great proponent of iconoclasm,
created two wonderful
statues in Edinburgh,
the Scottish capital.
One is of David Hume, the
other is of Adam Smith.
They're beautiful statues,
they stand on the Royal Mile.
Tourists assume they've been there
for at least a hundred years,
(audio distortion) barely 10 years old.
And I think Sandy Stoddart
could be well employed
in the United States,
creating some beautiful new statues,
to whatever it is that we think
should be the heroes of our time.
That would be a far better
employment of public energy
than the kind of vandalism
that we see these days.
- So since this is our July 4th week show,
and I've got a noted historian on,
give me a little American history
that maybe the average
person watching this,
give me something, an anecdote, a story,
a moment that the average
person watching this
maybe doesn't know that much about.
That they should know.
Is there something that
sticks out to you as,
oy, more people should know
about that story, that moment?
- Well I suspect, in a crowded field,
I'd be bound to choose
one of those episodes
that really paved the
way for the United States
to become, not just a
hugely successful republic,
more successful than
any previous republic,
but a great power, even a super power.
And the temptation for
republics, historically,
has always been at a certain point,
for the temptations power
to steer the republic to tyranny.
This very nearly happened during
Harry Truman's presidency,
at the time of the Korean war,
when a rogue figure, Douglas MacArthur,
quarreled with Truman about the
direction of the Korean war.
MacArthur actually was
in favor of dropping
atomic bombs on China to end the war.
And it came to a clash,
that to another republic,
that might have been fatal.
Think of the fate of the Roman republic,
which ultimately became an empire,
as the mighty figure
of Augustus ultimately
sucked the life out of the
institutions of the republic.
But I think that the
showdown that happened then,
between Truman and MacArthur,
Truman's successful
assertion of the primacy
of the civilian authority,
is a hugely important
moment in American history.
Truman was a great president
in a whole range of ways.
He is best known for the famous line,
"The buck stops here."
But it stopped there in
a very important way.
When Truman asserted the
primacy of the presidency
against the charismatic
military figure who,
when he returned to the United States,
had a ticker tape parade in New York.
You watch the scenes of MacArthur's return
at that time of crisis,
when it seemed he might make
a presidential bid himself,
you realize that the United States
was teetering on the
brink of a Roman outcome,
but pulled back.
And I want to emphasize that episode,
which isn't well-known,
because you should always keep in mind
the history of what hasn't happened,
what didn't happen, even if it nearly did.
You have to keep it alive in your mind
all the times that this
republic might have fallen
from the path of democracy
and the rule of law.
And remind yourself,
when you're feeling down,
as some people occasionally do feel down
contemplating our politics,
that American democracy has
never been a fairy story.
When Charles Dickens
came to the United States
in the 19th century,
he was appalled by the
viciousness of American politics,
by its venality, by the rule
of money, by the corrupt press.
We shouldn't tell ourselves that
there's some golden age in the past
that we've somehow lapsed from.
I think that's a very common
failing that Americans have.
They're always telling themselves
it was so much better
in those good old days.
Pick a decade, the 50s, the 80s.
But I don't think that's the right way
to think about American history.
I think it's better to realize
that the republic experiment,
the with this particular Constitution,
was always going to be fraught with peril.
But the Founding Fathers knew
that somebody like Donald Trump
would become president at some point.
That was why they designed
the Constitution the way they did.
Alexander Hamilton was
very explicit about that
in the Federalist Papers and elsewhere.
So, I think, as an immigrant,
my advice to Americans is,
don't have this fantasy, America,
that you keep failing to live up to,
that you feel you've somehow missed.
'Cause it never existed.
There's never been that fantasy, America.
There's always been an America
teetering on the brink,
with the separation of powers
threatening sometimes to collapse.
And as I've said, with
the temptations of empire,
periodically coming along
and say to the republic,
"Come on, be Rome."
And thus far, we've
always rightly said no.
- You're hopeful, my friend.
- Oh yeah, immigrants are.
- I sense you're hopeful.
- That's why we come here.
Remember, for all that Americans
love to hate in themselves,
this is still the number
one destination for people
who say they would like to leave
the country of their birth.
And it seems unlikely to me
that that would be the case,
if this really was the cesspit of racism
that it's so often described
as by progressives.
- Right, I love the Open
Borders crowd will also tell you
that we're an evil racist
patriarchical society,
and yet, everyone
apparently should come here
to share in the horror.
It's a slight foreign
thinking, don't you think?
- It is a paradox.
One thing that COVID-19 has done,
has been to remind everybody
that borders matter,
and that the health
and safety of citizens,
in fact, depend on secure borders,
where people coming even only
as visitors can be monitored.
And that I think is one of the important
and unexpected consequences
of the pandemic,
that isn't widely recognized.
Ultimately, President Trump's arguments
back in 2016 included the following,
that borders really mattered
and shouldn't be porous,
and that China was a problem
and a threat to our national security.
COVID-19 has illustrated both
those points pretty well.
- And here we are.
Dare I ask a historian to make
some political predictions?
- Go on.
The only point to studying history
is to understand the present
and plausible futures better.
(laughing)
- So you're gonna punt that one?
I mean, what do you think
is gonna happen over there?
If you had to just sorta generally paint
the next couple of months,
where do you think we're at?
- I think what's going to
happen is what happened in 2016,
that opinion polls and approval ratings
will consistently predict
a Democratic victory.
And the media and the people
who work on American politics
will replicate the mistakes
that they made in 2016,
by looking ever more closely
at polls and prediction markets,
and then they will get a
very very big surprise.
Because I sense from revealed preferences,
as opposed to stated preferences,
that the country is far from convinced
that it should go down
the road of Open Borders
or defunding the police,
or a Green New Deal.
And the more they hear of those
radical ideas from Democrats,
the more upheaval they see
in the streets of American cities,
the more they quietly make a mental note
to vote Republican on November the 3rd.
But, of course, I could find
myself very badly wrong.
Anybody who makes a prediction about
American election in the Summer
is running the risk of engaging
in a kind of astrology.
But let me give you a data point, Dave.
It's very interesting,
and I've heard it from
many different quarters,
how many people have
bought firearms in 2020.
In the month of March-
- You're looking at one of them.
- And you're looking at
one of them too, Dave.
In the month of March alone,
the monthly background checks were doubled
what happened on average in 2019.
Now I'm gonna call that
a revealed preference.
I'm gonna suggest that
the months of May and June
may also see elevated purchases.
One of the most sure predictors
of a Republican vote in 2016,
was if a household possessed a firearm.
Households without firearms
overwhelmingly voted Democrat.
Houses with firearms
overwhelmingly voted Republican.
I'm just saying that
there are sources of data,
other than opinion polls,
that it would be prudent to look at,
at a time when people have
all kinds of incentives
to not be quite straight with pollsters.
Revealed preferences are
the things to look at.
And my sense is that
the mood of the country
is not being well understood
by the New York Times
or the Washington Post
or CNN at the moment.
I don't think it's been
well understood at all.
My nightmare though, to take
another stab at prediction,
is that we end up with a result like 2000,
that we end up with a tie.
I worry that Joe Biden
is a weak candidate,
and Donald Trump is in a recession,
having not handled COVID-19 brilliantly.
They're both weak.
And in that scenario,
you could imagine a 2000-like result,
but with multiple states
having their results contested
because of controversies
around postal voting.
And that would be the nightmare scenario
for the United States,
because it would not be
resolved as quickly as it was,
nor would the result be
accepted by the losing side
as quickly as it was in 2000.
So when I look into the crystal ball,
I do find myself hoping
for a decisive result,
because a tie of that sort,
I think would plunge us into weeks,
possibly months, of strive.
And it would be the perfect opportunity
for America's enemies to make any move
that they might have been considering.
- All right, we can't end on this,
because you've actually been
quite uplifting throughout,
and have a firm belief in America.
So you've gotta bring me
home on something positive.
Give me something here,
to bring it altogether.
- Well I think, as I said,
worrying about this stuff
is probably the best
way to prepare for it,
and divert a disaster.
There's still time actually to make sure
that we don't have multiple
contested results from states.
It's, as we speak, not yet July 4th.
In the same way, looking back,
that we can learn from what went wrong
in this country in January and February.
Remember, the real
question for 2020 is not,
did President Trump get COVID-19 wrong?
The real question is
why did the Department of
Health and Human Services,
which has an Assistant
Secretary for Preparedness,
get it wrong?
Why did, what we sometimes
call the deep state,
fail so disastrously to get this right,
despite on paper, having multiple plans
for pandemic preparedness and bio defense?
So I think, we have the chance now
to start learning from mistakes
that were made back in January,
when we could have averted this
great economic catastrophe,
just by learning from what the Taiwanese
and the South Koreans did.
We still, I think, have the ability,
I don't think we've so lost our minds
that we've lost the ability,
to learn from obvious
mistakes of governance.
And we should learn from what
went wrong in that pandemic,
just as we should learn
from what went wrong
in some recent elections.
I mean, think of some
of the primary results
that descended into farce.
We've got to make sure, by
worrying about this issue,
that we don't have an
IOWA Caucus writ large
on November the 3rd.
You could imagine, you
understand the internet
as well as any public intellectual, Dave,
you can imagine the chaos
of conspiracy theories
we could be confronting
on November the 4th
if there is uncertainty.
So, you know, let's do what Americans
have long been famous for.
Here's a problem, let's fix
it with the can-do spirit.
That's what Europeans used to say,
distinguished Americans
from everybody else.
Let's fix the problems that
have revealed themselves
in our pandemic preparedness,
and in our electoral system.
We've just got time to do it,
and it will be, I think,
the perfect expression
of the American way,
if we fix it just in time.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about academia,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our Academia playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.